how useful a guide is what's happening
online to the reality of the political
story I to the two of the two sort of
interrelated and how much they overlap I
think it's pretty fundamental when you
look at the fact that everyone's got a
voice on social media rep and you're
looking at you know half a million
people tweeting in the 7-way debate
somewhat less on these five way debate
to 11 days ago that's 145,000 opinions
just on that that's and bite piece alone
so it could be argued I think that
social media and the presence sort of
blows oxygen into a campaign at various
points it then sub dies down and it flat
lines a little bit nothing we've seen
that in this particular election but at
certain times it I think it serves to
engage in in the in the debate I was
doing some very interesting stuff about
the way that's various social media
sites work and just as when you express
preferences towards products or anything
else out there social media tries to
show you more of what you might like and
so some of these social media sites can
turn into something of an echo chamber
where if you say you like a political
view on one side you just get more of
that view do you do you think that
that's something that's going to be a
significant phenomenon in elections
fitting it from now on I think it's a
growing phenomena manaan I think more
and more people are expressing
themselves on social media we've seen
the growth over the past ten years has
been exponential and yes there are there
are certain there's the retweeting for
instance so that people are expressing
an opinion of an opinion and so I think
there is a there's it's more of a sort
of a growth as a graph that develops
from a conversation and that and then
you get social architects that are
follow more closely and they're seen as
leaders on the web and so for instance
if Stephen Fry expresses an opinion then
that that informs a much broader
conversation than than if David Morgan
expresses an opinion I've short that's
not true I mean what can we learn from
the state's about this sorry what can we
learn from the US about this and we can
learn that it's here to stay and that a
strong investor
meant in understanding how people think
and feel on the web is something that is
not a choice anymore in an election
campaign it's a necessity and what are
the what are the stats tell us at the
moment then because I was just having a
little look at your websites and the
date would remind us of how it works but
basically you can look at what the last
24 hours has thrown up yeah I Ned
Miliband seems to be ahead on on just
mentions or is that positive mentions
yeah we look at sort of timelines from
the last five minutes right through the
last 30 days and we set up for the last
24 hours and and what we're looking at
is that Ed Miliband is climbing up the
credibility ladder right now he's
performed well in the televised debates
he's shown a human side to a politician
that's that is somewhat refreshing for
people out there with the sort of
corollary of that is someone like Nigel
Farage for instance who keeps dropping
hand grenades in the debate and is
becomes a Marmite figure and and what we
saw probably six to nine months ago that
Nigel Farage was actually living the
same category so Boris Johnson where
we've seen as refreshing says it how it
is slightly amusing but I think he's
what we've seen on social media is now
is polarizing effect as meant that
there's a lot of fear and uncertainty
around Nigel Farage which didn't make
for a good result just positive positive
played better online than negative
because David Cameron is now coming out
today we've certainly seen him doing it
traveling much more positive much more
passionate it's it's what you're looking
for is outliers on both sides you're
looking for highly things that highly
positive things that are highly negative
and scoring those accordingly and then
taking an overall view of a trend in how
people are thinking of feeling of the
Lee of the four major party has anything
surprised you on who's doing what on
which sort of topic because I was
slightly surprised how a David Cameron
seems to be dominating the health
conversation over the last 24 hours when
I was looking yes he eat it's it tends
to rise and fall with the statements of
the day but at the MS but what's what's
generally happening is that there's
there's nothing really new that
being that that's that's taking a you
know a thought leadership view in any of
the major topics but it does it does
flux yeah David thank you very much
David Morgan the CEO of it they say